he's got a new book out DDP yoga every
single time we see him he's doing better
and better and better
thank you thank you it's amazing hello
my wife Brenda hi of course sit down
publicist Beth
well welcome do you really like his
beard I just I'm not a fan
his beard DDP is positively paid he's
not gonna come in here on a negative
note no matter how much you tried no I
actually completely different look man
yes yeah you know yeah I think I think
of young William Shatner constantly
changing his stuff up go Chris Jericho
right Jericho changes all the loose
change up and now Sam Roberts you too
though you got to a point where you were
like I got to cut all the hair off you
admitted yeah dude I had to yeah and to
me you've always got to be reinventing
yourself sometimes it doesn't work right
you know and what are they tried that
didn't work well when I did when I came
back to wrestling after I tore my
rotator cuff I went with really dark
hair and it just wasn't a really good
look for me I'm a natural blonde I'm you
know ginger redhead but Bill every
summer my hair would all be all bleached
out by serpent so yeah I was always like
a strawberry type blonde type guy and
that just makes me look healthier and
then I look at some of the looks up we
just finished a documentary called
relentless and it just it goes from when
I blew my back out and 99 mm-hmm today
because we have all this footage of this
entire journey from you know DDP yoga
and in olds all the stuff we're doing
and there's some times but I was using
that what's that called honey that
Grecian formula 44 for men or whatever
that was not a good look we have a
co-worker that he's an older gentleman
at this point and he uses a shampoo hair
dye combination it's not the greatest in
the world he dyes his hair with the same
paint they use on a subway car
just broad strokes well work out for me
for those that don't know DDP he's got
an amazing story and I feel like your
story just as you go it just keeps
getting kind of more and more amazing
there's always something tacked on to
the end every time you go you start pro
wrestling when you're like what 35 is
there right there we probably office so
that's when you start training to be a
wrestler yeah and obviously everybody's
going you know your times up your times
past it's not gonna happen
you know you're out of your mind you
become WCW world champion at by the way
wrestling's hottest point this is during
the Monday Night Wars is a Goldberg and
stone cold and the rock and everything
and you're how old when you're WCW
champion for the first time well I I
came back I was 43 right because I
ruptured my l4 and l5 which is where the
whole DDP yoga thing comes from and you
know it looked like I was never going to
come back so for me to be able to come
back after three top spine specialist
tell me you're done and then three
months later I'm back you know and then
I'm in the ring with Hogan sting and
flair right I mean three you can do
arguably people will argue that they're
the best three of all time yeah I mean
and there's there's there's so and
there's so many guys that are
interchangeable from Stone Cold to you
know to Dusty Rhodes to whoever Jake the
snake Roberts but bottom line is I was
in a ring with three the biggest names
of all time and I'll tell you after that
match was over and Hulk had me put him
out in Bret Hart's figure-four leglock
on the ring boat so it really looks like
it hurts like hell and I'm sure if I
wanted it to it could but he has he had
a bad knee and he needed to get work
done and he wanted to sort of set things
up in an angle for us down the road and
so he went during that four-way dance we
did he left early yo in the match and
then when I got the world title and I
walked back in the locker room it was
just being Hulk and yours so you by the
way you win that match where you got
sting and flair and how again right you
know it's good yeah Ric Flair I thanked
him I never really thanked him properly
because we had a little bit tension in
our careers with each other how come I
just I don't even know but I I never
wanted
because I love Ric Flair you know and
about eight year nine years ago when um
when they drop all the balloons for him
and WWE it was like the real retirement
for somebody I thought may not gonna fix
this with this yummy I'm gonna try so
we're both that agree or at both signing
in Jersey and we're both in the
greenroom
and Ric came in he got flooded with
everybody and then he turns around
swinging him he's like hey diamond I'm
like hey Rick can talk to you for a sec
it's like sure of course I said hey man
I listen I know over the years me and
you have had heat together you guys all
diamond don't worry about that like a
Rick I'm not worried about it I want to
try and fix it I said I don't know what
happened I really don't I know I know
I've said some stuff I know you said
some stuff I go I don't want to feel
this way about you bro I know I love Ric
Flair I said I would love to start all
over again and I put my hand out and I
said I'm Diamond Dallas Page and he
popped god bless you brother and bottom
I was 9 years ago and I've had the
greatest relationship with Rick since
then so I never really got that thank
him the way I wanted to because of the
ego you were getting long yeah you know
I thanked him but I mean I didn't really
thank him but when I went in the Hall of
Fame in 2017 I got a chance to really
thank him and it was it just felt so
good and I know he felt good about it
and then we're getting ready to leave
like you know you stayed there for four
days when you go down for the Hall of
Fame you've been down there and that
night before Rick and I are at the bar
and he goes so what time is your flight
I said 7:30 he's like oh look that I go
Nami and he's like you're not taking
that plate you just stole in Atlanta
right I said yeah I got a Learjet you've
read they're coming home earlier jet and
limousine ride and Learjet fly Ric Flair
he found that it was my birthday and
then I let me go home so he took me and
Brenda to dinner
and you know you're just this is super
special guy and I'm just so glad that
were you know awesome everything is good
yeah what did you do before you rested
only a 35 would you do before that I was
in a nightclub business I was running a
nightclub since I was 22 you know and
it's so funny to meet Jake the snake
Roberts like if I let me just the back
the story is I tried to wrestle when I
was 22 I had three matches I sucked I
hurt my knee and I got my first
opportunity to run up just a it was a
rock and roll bar you know one bar band
in the back small but it was fun and
I've been in business since I was 17
started a day crew bouncer bartender I'd
done everything except for managed and I
get to manage this place what was it it
was in South Orange New Jersey it was
close it's called 23 Valley Street and
there was three bars right next to each
other so it's a great little hub and
what happened was I got that opportunity
right after I banged my knee up and I
was starting to wrestle and I sort of
got away from the dream I left it you're
making money and I suppose abroad yeah
it's a flop Yeah right
when you're managing a nightclub or
you're able to beat women no it was a
lot of fun and I kind of got lost right
and I didn't really yeah I was making
good money and I had a great time and I
sort of left the dream of yo and I
haven't time I said go over myself I
pretty much come pretty close to hidden
art or I rock it past it and I just sort
of lost it and then I'm flicking the
channels though in 80s it's like 78 79
you know I'm 62 so you know wrestling
hadn't blown up yet but in a couple of
years in the 80s it blew up you know it
was local mania and everything and I was
so mad that I didn't pay my dues I
stopped watching wrestling and then one
day I was flicking the channels and I
see Gorilla Monsoon and this guy with
this do-rag and the freaking sunglasses
and it's Jesse Ventura we're just
talking about him and I yeah yeah I mean
he he pulled me in like I was this yeah
I got dressed up was Halloween that year
yeah but the next match that came out he
had a bag over
older and it's Jake the snake Roberts
I'm like who is this guy so now I'm
sucked back in watching and I can app I
leave that club that I was at I end up
in a club down in Fort Myers Florida
that I'm running and it's a big place
now we got 10 got six bars 12 bartenders
your place is hopping no a thousand plus
people in the weekends so if you're in
Miami and you're going to Tampa and
you're wrestling like you do a loop yeah
different areas well that's 300 miles
right in the middle is Fort Myers so
Jake stopped off there and I was in the
back and I'm looking at the me do the
cameras at the front door I'm thinking
god I looks like Jake snake Roberts so I
run around the outside of the building
because it was too packed in the
building in the club I run around the
outside and I go to my girl the front
door I go cutie I just walk in here look
like Jake snake Roberts
everybody thinks it's him so I go
running around the corner when I see him
I slow down because I gotta be cool I
walked up to him and I said hey man I go
you Jake the snake Roberts who wants to
know I said the guy runs the place he
goes yeah I said what are we drinking
yeah so he gets by the way who wants to
know and you go the guy that runs the
place he's like okay free dream property
I am you know Jake when you really think
about it we came drinking buddies you
can come in occasionally Ted DiBiase
bushwhackers Jannetty and Michaels I
mean so many guys came through there but
the whole thing with Jake you really
think about we start off his drinking
buddies and then later in the
resurrection a jig snake I'm trying to
get him to stop drinking well here's the
here's the wild thing about DDP is that
so you know he comes back to wrestling
he comes up with this yoga method for
himself he starts to develop it into a
business he starts teaching other people
he starts you know coming out with DVDs
and all this stuff and you know the
thing about wrestlers is that they're
all carnies right like wrestling is a
carny business so I went DDP yoga came
out when you started pushing this thing
I'm like sitting there going like okay
like I like DDP but what's the angle
here like
you know they mean and then cuz you
don't think yoga is very masculine is
how what you're saying with this isn't
your mom is a different type of yoga but
no I'm going like okay like this is a
this is a sales job right because a lot
of wrestlers will do stuff like that but
then what DDP did was he goes I'm gonna
take Jake the snake Roberts and I'm
gonna take Scott Hall who was Razor
Ramon and these are two guys that for
the longest time anybody that had like a
wrestler Dethklok list thing these are
the two biggest sort of tragedy stories
attics
you know just messed up all the time
every three months another story like
just waiting to get that awful phone
call one day and DDP legit moved him
into his house said I'm gonna get you
guys better filmed the whole thing and
all of a sudden you go holy [ __ ] this
thing is real yeah the doctor was great
I mean this is real yeah anybody who
hasn't seen it say it's on Amazon Prime
right now and Hulu just picked it up as
well and it's very cool because other
people will get a chance to see it and I
always tell people if you've got someone
you should do a lot of rule of wrestling
flam's listen to your show but a lot of
us or not wrestled there he's at but I
challenge I challenge anybody who hates
wrestling because it's not about
wrestling to watch no resurrection Jake
the snake because it'll it'll definitely
change your skew you know on what you
think
and by the way showed ugly stuffing like
it's not this like you know we filmed
everything yeah it was over 500 hours
and my buddy Steve you is the president
of DP y which now I'm branding
everything as you can see Danny why why
because I want people to stop calling it
just yoga cuz it's not you here one of
the lifestyle gym people you have you
ever done yoga um I mean I not try this
I've tried to tried
yeah but minimum I can't have even done
I fought for a few weeks you had you
tried hot yoga no idea what it was sure
if you walked into that you walked
mine you go what the [ __ ] is this rises
in yoga right like yes but no hmm so you
know bottom line is I'm trying to get
people to stop calling in yoga and it's
going to just yoga I don't good with DDP
yoga but I'm it's all about branding
everything it's like this is what's the
name of the show Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts right if it was Bill yo Tuesday
and Sam Wednesday that would be name
right people would know how to find it
you got it and say and you got to give
something that people can understand and
so you know DDP why like the people
could say peanut p90x if they could say
that and everybody knows what p90x is
tell me what it means right nobody no no
close nobody knows no clue but it was a
great workout and it didn't have a
billion units so I don't see it worked
what do you do for 90 days that was that
was a 90 day yeah but you know everybody
would say p90x you can say DDP why it's
gonna take me about three years but
that's a little piece of the brandy and
throwing it out there into the universe
we got me when it started it wasn't DDP
yoga it was no regular for regular guys
right right and it's like reinventing
itself great reinventing itself I just
we're about to and it's not yet but I
know what's so close I could talk about
it we're about to sign a partnership
with the NFL alumni Wow how cool is that
you know that's huge that's huge because
we gonna be able to help you and I'm
keeping it to these guys yeah you know I
want to there's gonna be a couple a
little start and then those guys are
gonna see their friends start to feel
better they're gonna see them start to
get more mobile they're gonna start to
see them get stronger they might lose
weight you know whatever it is it was
never about weight loss which they're
you happen to see the video that went
viral over Christmas which one there's
you always have enough this is it's good
guys in with Vance Hines he was easy
District Attorney
okay 470 pounds now this is how it
happens this is how powerful the
internet is Bert Kreischer someone is
awesome 470 pounds yes
so I said the bird you should have DDP
on your podcast and he said I'd love to
have DDP on my podcast so I went over to
follow Bert and I see this guy he's got
a camera and he's holding the camera out
and he's video himself without his shirt
on
he's 475 pounds he's an attorney he's 52
years old now you know how those guys do
the sober October 3rd yeah so last sober
October he's sitting there and they're
talking you and and Chrysler says I'm
gonna run a half a marathon and they're
going Yeah right [ __ ] you you ain't
running a thing no making fun of them
hmm he ran it when you know he filmed
himself going over the finish line the
whole deal and when when Vance saw bad
he thought you know what if Burt can get
off the phone I'm get off the couch so
can I so here I see you about a month
and a half later he's down about 15
pounds so I just tweeted him I said hey
man if you never need any help I can see
you serious let me know and he DM me
back and he said I'm sorry but I had no
idea to hell you were but when he said
you offered help you know my Twitter lit
up saying that you could have you you
can get DD peas up you don't take it
you're crazy he said I used to say no to
everything he said now I'm saying yes to
everything yes I'll take your help one
year to the day Jimbo one year to the
day he lost 198 pounds
Jesus Wow and that's just from eating
real food and and eating real food and
doing my workouts but not just say also
walking - cuz he couldn't really walk
that far in the beginning but you get
stronger you can do things that you want
to do and then you want to do jiu-jitsu
now go do it I love jiu-jitsu but not
good for you like you're not you're 52
you're a beat up athlete and no no I can
do it I can do it let me tell you what's
gonna happen you're gonna get hurt
you're gonna feel good and then you're
gonna push yourself and you're gonna get
hurt doesn't that what people said to
you yeah but if you I must say never do
I'm just saying not yet you went there
you 340 pounds
let's get you down in twos and bottom
line is he hurt himself how do you hurt
themselves just doing judicious yeah you
don't because you know you start rolling
and if you're keeping it really nice
where you're just going from one move to
another it's easy but then ego kind of
steps in here's kind of think I can get
he's not gonna do this to me and I think
I think jujitsu is the greatest every
single kid should do it because bottom
line is if bullies and everything you
know jujitsu how many bullies gonna be
screwing right yeah yeah it's a great
learn to yet I saw photos of you and
Matt Serra shirtless and I couldn't tell
the difference and I was on the left is
totally bald look at that
yeah I know Matt Serra the UFC fighter
oh yeah yeah so we uh
but he hasn't she isn't you haven't
looked into learning in because you were
talking about doing I know I want to do
but I have sleep out there
terrible terrible sleeper so I'm always
tired and it's like Jimmie Rivera from
the yo he reached out to me he's like
doing like he has a gym not far from my
house like I'm just really stupid I did
something that's I want to do it you
know if you just start doing it's like
you I just tell everybody to just start
doing anything more active you get the
more energy you'll have yeah and then it
comes down to food like what you're
eating I try to educate people you know
watch Food Inc watch genetic roulette
and when you understand what they've
done to our food you'll kind of
understand why you're so lethargic but I
don't understand I watched these babies
actually pretty good
like I have three Donuts every morning
you're just lucky you have great
genetics you can stay skinny thank you
but you're like skinny fat i watch all
these documentaries though and i feel
like every time you turn one on it's
another food and another food and
another food and i haven't found what
you can actually eat i feel like no
matter what there is some documentary
that will tell you this isn't good to
you this is bad yeah yeah but no excuse
I just made I see yes but no
you know people get you know comedians
especially busting balls on Oh God
organic this or organic that or organic
would sweat like what our
great-grandparents used to call food
raised everything was [ __ ] organic
you know I mean like everything and now
it's not right and if you only want to
if you look at the numbers in the last
30 years
what's that wood cancer like through the
roof think of the pesticides on the
vegetables like take any pesticide spray
it on your tongue see what happens I've
had worship your tongue
[Laughter]
what would you say at this point is the
thing that like you're most proud of
because the you you you put out this
book positively unstoppable the art of
owning it and it is like what I like
about what you're doing is everything's
in here right it's not like if you buy
this then you buy that and then you buy
that like I was reading it and it's part
your story it's part all the yoga
techniques it's part resin techniques
yoga didi if you want hey why do i do go
dynamic resistance there's all this part
DDP wide techniques but it's it like
it's everything packed into the book but
what would what do you think is the
thing that you're most proud of because
you had the Arthur video that you've
seen Jim that went everywhere that kind
of launched the whole thing I think you
know Jake's movie yeah because of what
you wasn't wasn't for Jake I'm not
sitting here and I always like you know
there's times where her I gotta go to
because Jake's up yo Jake come in to
stay with me all the time and and I my
daughter Lexi she said one time she said
something about Jake and is he coming
back I said yeah she was she was how
come you guys are so tight I said Lexi
probably not living in this house if it
wasn't for Jake you know I remember you
him and Dusty Rhodes and helping me yeah
back in the day so you know for me that
movie it meant so much and it it really
it changed so many people's lives and
then you know maybe the next thing is
like this positively unstoppable book
because it's actually it's everything
that I try to teach everybody but I
can't talk to one person all the time
I can specialize and I really work with
people like if you know how many people
I was working with right now that have
reached out and put the video out just
like Vance did and then I've reached out
to and then I give him the list and the
list which is in the book
yeah tells you all the things you need
to do like what did Arthur do what did
Vance do what did Stacy Morris do they
took they did they took the pictures
they took the measurements they wrote
their goals they started writing down
what they ate they literally started
changing their life they actually
started owning it that's what they did I
using one example after another and
positively unstoppable and when you have
that it's almost like I'm with you going
through it with you and the bottom line
is if I see you online and I see you
working your ass off and you're getting
these transformation your wouldn't work
in your gonna hear from me you guys are
right because I really do when you see
at real GDP or at DDP yoga on Twitter or
Instagram at Diamond Dallas Page or at
DDP yoga sometimes people on Twitter
will get a little upset with me no go
man DDP you're filling up my feed I'm
writing all inspiring things to all the
people I go hey monkey I'm not doing it
for you stop [ __ ] following me you
know just never yeah I don't care if you
don't want to see this stuff I'm writing
get rid of me don't follow me right I
don't care verse three thousand people
are thirty three million I want the
three thousand they're actually paying
attention how do you a couple years ago
you were on Raw and you you showed up
and the segment that you were on you got
you were wearing a DDP yoga t-shirt
you're on TV like it was basically just
a commercial for what you're doing yeah
and I'm sitting there going
how does DDP just show up in Vince's
like hey you want a commercial and they
don't and it'll blur out the other thing
they're like holding his foot up in the
air doing a moot like he's teaching DDP
yoga on the show to the characters and
I'm calling like this is literally the
greatest commercial anyone could ask for
there's a great story behind that but I
gotta tell you I know a lot of people
have been asking me all about and we'll
get to this I'm sure Cody Rhodes and
what's happening with aew and are you
gonna go there it's like you have to
understand I love Cody's like my nephew
and I will help him and do whatever he
needs me to do but I'm a WWE guy and I'm
a WWE guy cuz it wasn't the greatest
when I got there but the last eight
years have been amazing and Jim on GDP
showed up to WWE for the first time the
story line that they sacked him with was
he was stalking The Undertaker's wife
and everybody sat there and like he
revealed himself and everybody's like
pop would happen well because you were
there but then really quickly
everybody's like why would DDP be
stalking his wife maybe not like that
storyline
no let's beat down to WCW guys let's
beat him down bad but you know it was
okay because I just I knew I had just
breathe and just keep my mouth shut and
eventually that's what I did in WCW was
gonna rise back up especially with the
Hall of Fame and they gave me so many
opportunities from being the host of you
know the Monday Night Wars as far as
right you know the night best of nitro
there were so many cool things on that
show particularly they started bringing
me in four different shows too which was
great but that show particularly that
was show that Jake was gonna show up the
one that we're talking over you got your
commercial on Raw yeah and nobody knew
nobody knew except for me and you know
Triple H Vince of course and Jake and
they had Jake super hidden stuck in a
bus and everything and Triple H came up
to me those are ideas just do do that
thing you do can't get your stuff over
and put you through the foot over the
head thing people love that
you know that's how cool they've been to
me so you know I'm a loyal guy you know
they've been really good to me that's
amazing that you just show up they're
like just get your [ __ ] over and there's
no get became it was amazing
now let me tell you what happened from
that yeah it shut our servers down like
we got hit with so much traffic that it
shut our servers down for DDP yoga calm
that we couldn't we couldn't you know
sell anything for like eight hours so
here's what that was a godsend because
we're about to go on short tank about
nine months later which I was reading
about just last night and if if that
doesn't happen to us my business partner
Steve you doesn't come up with the idea
of let's put on twenty five servers as
opposed to one right so when if because
if we're gonna get hit we made a million
dollars of a shark tank without a deal
in five days five days I mean it put us
on the map that year it literally and
they play it all the time I know so you
must get those hits okay so as you can
see we literally just talking about
you're in the break every shark tank is
on Hulu so people go crazy for it and
CNBC all the time
literally plays nine hours of Shark Tank
four days a week so all when we're on
that rotation right anyways it always
gives us some sort of credibility and it
does good pops are saying they didn't
give you is no deal though no well I
didn't I wasn't gonna give them any kind
of money if everybody's gonna give I
didn't want their money to begin with
because we were already successful by
that time all this the story about it is
actually great because you talk about
not only once you got there but getting
there they make you sign this contract
apparently right we're even if you don't
get a deal ABC gets a cut of the
business ABC gets to control the
promotion of the business so you can't
be going on other shows I wouldn't be
able to come on here I would have to
check with them first right if I was
gonna do it like a little fox thing
we're coming being a DDP yoga workshop
they want to film me I would had to call
ABC first it was ridiculous is that
forever no it would only over an
18-month period for it but for the next
18 months but yeah
when that contract first came out the 5%
that ABC gotten that was locked in in
perpetuity right in booty what you got a
deal or not but they did kill that they
did could they stop doing it that year
but what had happened was the thing I
learned if I just did my business a
little differently when I went to WWE if
I'd worried don't want a dead shark tag
would hold up its story if I would have
got up from the table and said Vince
this is an awesome idea this stalker
angle but not for me when you want to do
people's champion versus people's
champion give me a call the people's
champion was a rock has biggest star in
the world now which everybody is so
freaking proud of man because he is he
is the man but at the time I was
originally two peoples champion and he
was using it so it would have been a
great angle if I would have said you
know what if I would have just got up
from the table and walked away so I
thanked Vince so many times and you know
last time was when I wanted the whole
thing but I thank them because if I
didn't go through that I would never
would have learned you got it if you
really believe in yourself you need to
get up and walk away from the table
so Shark Tank took me five interviews
and then they make you fill out 27 pages
of of [ __ ] basically signing everything
over it to give them control and I was
getting ready to go to Chattanooga and
my business partner Steve says he's like
hey bro what we can do about the you
know the contract I go here's her she
gonna do send him an email say I
appreciate the opportunity we love the
show but we're gonna pass and he went
what we've been working on this for two
years I go dude I can't let anybody put
me in a box again I said we will either
make it on what we're doing or I'm not
gonna press agency he's gonna make you
stalk the Undertaker's wife again you're
gonna stop it wouldn't be a good idea so
bottom line is it was a great move they
called me 90 minutes later as I was
pulling in Chattanooga how do we fix
this and it just I mean I learned and
you told them what you didn't want in
the contract I don't that yeah and four
contracts later I finally signed it you
know and
it was the greatest experience for my
company it was just as a businessman it
was an amazing Shark Tank is they
they'll be around forever I think it's
the best show ever and it's real reality
now it's not that [ __ ] reality it's
like what you see now you don't get to
see everything because it's an hour they
film you mr. wonderful blood point looks
at Steve and he goes so uh let me ask
you know in the world of fitness you
know that back then it was Beachbody
gyeom which is yoga and really nobody
else everybody else you could feel the
steel probably the the Met Center with
you know all the DVDs that celebrities
are athletes have done to try to sell
you know Jane Fonda did it well when it
worked she did that but most workout
videos from the 80s Yeah right oh yeah
those as a young as a younger man I
didn't but I peeked at them when I could
flex one lady you know for a communist
he's like how do you guys how do you
guys make the money and Steve said we
inspire people yeah yeah yeah that's
great
but how do you mr. wonderful it's not
trying to hear that this or doesn't care
what you're doing to people and unless
it's it's it's fishing money out of
their pocket do we inspire people that's
what we do like that's our method of how
we get the word out you know it's it's
like positively unstoppable the book you
know right now we decided we're gonna do
a positively unstoppable challenge where
if people go to positive positively
unstoppable calm they can sign up if
they transform their body it's gonna be
your body and your mind we're doing
they'll have a chance to win 1 million
dollars Jesus it's how you know if they
transform their mind they might just be
lying no you got to write stuff oh yeah
there's gonna be written stuff in there
and it'll it'll be questions and
there'll be a written thing at the end
so the body is ok this is an example if
you're gonna take pictures you know the
person it's a suit two people look it's
kind of similar that is great for months
transformation
this person has a newspaper that says
January 21st on it and the other person
doesn't that person's gonna go up the
ladder because they can qualify
everything videoing their workouts like
the thing that was so amazing about
Vance Heinz his work his video is he
filmed himself everywhere we had like he
said when we made a video for him we
probably had about close to 400 hours
cuz he would tape his workouts he just
zipped through some of that but to catch
him talking you know and actually have
that moment where he's desperate and so
many people don't have hope and this guy
inspired so many people we did over 22
million hits of views on YouTube in
seven days oh my god 22 million its
friends of are going dude I've seen that
video like three times it's going around
the horn people sharing it yeah like I'm
how cool is that
and that's that's him right up there you
know Vance loses 198 pounds in one year
and you know it's it's a great story and
he's just he's a great guy yeah now uh
handsome Rob over here I didn't know I
literally didn't know this until this
morning he's sitting there in the office
and we're just kind of chatting about
what we're gonna do on the show today
and he goes and this is a quote Travis
put it on the prep sheet for us I love
DDP yoga
it's fun it's awesome you get to make
the workout your own like he's doing the
lines and I'm going no Rob you know and
he's like yeah he never mentioned it he
never told us he does DDP yoga Rob D do
you wanna uh do you have a favorite DDP
yoga I'm a big fan of the red core
workout right cool
red hot yeah yeah you don't know these
though right red hot core no I don't
it's great it's like I imagine it works
on you right and it's just abs and it's
awesome do you want to see some examples
I'd love to okay actually or picture
because I got it in December you really
are
or anything like that I just figured I
saw these videos of people getting
transformed and everything I was like
you started as a twink what do you want
to be I want to give like kind of more
cut bucks yeah you want to get buff yes
you want to be a hunk Rob yeah yes I do
want to be a hunk right now he spends
the world
let me see your before and after
pictures bro well you know this isn't a
second I would I talked to you three
days ago I would have told you if I had
known this is what happens dude we got
it we got in the car the other day my
wife and I we were leaving my friend
Kent bachelor's party we got in an uber
and then we know we're talking and we
weren't talking to the driver and at
some point I say something about DDP oh
he goes oh man the driver goes that
stuff really works
he goes I do it from my back I've gotten
all verbal my back paid you got I mean
what he did for Jericho that's why I did
it
and Brenda goes do you look in your
rear-view mirror yet oh my god gdb this
is the funny part though when he pulled
up I go ahead man you mind if I sit in
the front seat
no no y'all sit in the back the back and
she goes and you would let him sit in
the front you just want me to pull over
right now you could shake why would he
say no to sitting in the front some
people don't want to be right there you
out there yeah yeah well I wouldn't feel
much safer with you behind me I mean
we've all seen the Clemenza scene look
at the intense look on Rob's face in his
before the guy from 10:00 to midnight
who's running naked down the street the
Bronson had to kill what a creep this is
this is this is the cover of the New
York Post and it says manifesto under
after one because I'm not finished
what's that group of guys that are mad
that they can't get laid Oh insults this
looks like an insane membership card
I'll teach them to tease me take off my
shirt
what are you doing no I closed the
button shirt he takes them both off like
it's a is there is there is there DDP
why move that can shrink the nipple
sighs that's embarrassed but I feel a
lot better I feel more energized every
day it's good the absolute right thing
that works on the muscle tone of the
arms of the chest or it like you just do
it ABS that's something no I'm doing it
sounds like you're saying it's meaty
breasts not meaty no we got a diamond
dozen a lot because two years ago I had
a herniated disc and a pinched nerve
from golf and that's like my favorite
sport ever right and so I'm trying to
just get it fixed so for how long you
been doing it
I started in December so oh yeah my
here's here's well I wanted to tell you
work your way up to that diamond kind of
workout yeah or that double black
diamond because that that that'll really
work your whole body big-time oh goes
from like my beginner workout start in
bed like you can't get out of bed I got
three workouts for you in bed but I hope
you get in a chair and then I got eight
workouts in a chair but I hope you get
out of the chair and use the chair and
then you work your way to beginner
intermediate stuff I'm talking about
it's like advanced stuff that well not
only because of you're not just
stretching you're stretching and
strengthening the muscles ligaments and
tendons that you end up in a spot where
your comp I want to know how far you're
long your long shot is right now that's
right fear drive and where it's gonna be
next year okay like it will increase
that bad guys increased 60 yards yeah
about 60 before you put your shirt on I
need it's important to know I think if
you've got the guy right here you don't
want to be doing it wrong the whole time
so don't you think some of this
technique should be $100 get you on
using dynamic resistance all right so
what I want you doing is small
yes they're not even the same species
it's a man talking to his son now turn
it in there you go now slightly bend
your knees now I want you to grip your
toes into the mat or your sneakers no no
no no no no bends over used to I don't
want you to try smaller man yes sir okay
spread your legs to grab your ankle so
what I'm trying to do what I'm trying to
do here is get him engaging muscles
because every time you flex her and get
your muscle your heart has to beat
faster get your blood in a muscle of
course so again you got your heart
monitor one night now
put your heart bar on right now let's
get that heart rate up let's get it up
let's get it up let's see where you're
at
come on Rob today what's your heart rate
monitor wait wait you got the Apple
watch on here Jesus Christ he's doing
thanks a lot for nothing Tim Cook oh
yeah
Steve Jobs would have had his heart rate
going already of course you would have
okay we're looking for a number c56040 I
watch it Jimbo right there 63 these are
mine I'm 63 all right so let's see what
happens when he starts engaging flexor
muscles okay so what I want you to do
right is I want you to grip your toes
and your sneakers okay now I want you to
try to pull your feet together but don't
move them work the adductors tuck your
tailbone squeeze your glutes reach out
and grab the ball over those fingers
wide wide wide awesome please round at
your own resistance as you're moving
inhale take it up higher push your
summit index fingers together tight
tight tight and dance like a god thank
you bye yeah arms out through a t-shirt
67 that's what's that true look at that
look at it that's all right look at that
well DDP left on now DDP left it's like
it's like I was back in glory left a
welt on Rob's chest okay I can take my
heart rate from like I walk around
around 80 85 sometimes 90 I think about
heart and 1340 that quitting that
quickly did that hurt your chest Rob a
little bit yeah let me tell you
something Rob it is it is an honor to
beat you can for your life say that DDP
chop to you yeah that's a good shot
that's a good job look at that I was
left-handed it's not bad good job thank
you yeah yeah yeah
if DDP chopped me and left that mark on
my chest I get it tattooed on Jim would
you like to get chopped across the chest
no I would not tell me that I would not
see if he's a large man what are you six
five six four yeah he's big guy and I
used to be like 260 I hated that weight
it was too big for me
I like a lamb like 213 it's a good
weight easier on my knees yeah you know
it's at 62 I'm constantly trying to hold
back the heads of time so you know I
don't want to be beating my body up too
much well you look like you're a better
shape now than you were when you started
wrestling in your 30s yeah it's funny
because a lot of people say that the
wear and tear of that road is
unbelievable right you know Chris
Jericho was just with him um out on his
that tort that both crews he did he
didn't crew Jericho did a wrestling in
Rock oh don't worry dude comedians yeah
bands he had wrestling yeah it was crazy
man it was sold out it was people had a
really great time Brad Williams did it
did he okay and Chris Young Christian I
do yeah Chris seven years ago herniating
is l4 just like and I blew up my l4 and
l5
but Chris herniated his l4 it couldn't
sing couldn't couldn't maybe was done
rustling they've done I turned him on my
dt py program in five weeks he was 85%
pain-free in three months he was a
hundred percent pain-free in headline
WrestleMania with CM Punk and let's
forget about that that was seven years
ago
he just headlined in the main event at
Tokyo Dome in a main event at 48 years
old and they stole the show and he just
I mean they just he just they just
launched a new promotion around him as
the biggest star you know like it's a
well I couldn't be any happier for
Jericho because everything like if
anybody gets owning it it's Chris
Jericho yeah and like like he wrote me a
really nice thing for the book he read
the book and we're actually gonna do
something with at the end of this month
talking about it but uh you know we
become really good friends out of the
business and you know for so long I
wanted liked it to pay him back for
telling everybody because he told
everybody about it and he gave me a
letter a level of credibility amongst
the boys thank yourselves and now yeah
it's probably 50 different of the guys
who are top guys who do my stuff you
know how's your chest it's a little
painful the heart rate is still up isn't
it chop that was a baby chop that was
like an off angle left-handed that
wasn't your doctor D David Schultz
watching him you know you ever see that
clip where he slapped John Stossel in
his ear oh of course that recently
actually for some reason no man it's a
shame because it ruined his career you
know yeah right yeah because stossel
knew about it but he didn't think you
know she was gonna hit him like that you
know but he'll be nuts it's not checkers
that's how we hit each other sometimes
he know you're gonna hit him he knew I
know and then all of a sudden he did it
and Dave had to take the frigging here
to take ours
when he got you know booted booted down
you know cuz you know he never wrestled
again you ever saw him and I loved
watching that kind of ring wrestle he's
legit badass yeah he's uh he's a bounty
hunter like the real deal that he does
now I know he was doing that for years I
mean now I never got to meet him buddy
though it was always I was always a big
fan of him he says no no he's a lot but
he's there's certain guys in the ring
you see him in a ring you say man that's
a that's a real-life badass right there
would you get back in the ring and do
anything or are you not now you know I'd
still if WWE called me to do a diamond
cutter or something yeah jump in the
Royal Road I nice cutter I catch you out
of nowhere with my move and we go
I mean we're going you're going
faceplant first and if you can go with
me and it's kind of you're good or
you're I can take you and you're going
so the diamond cutters you move yeah it
really was the thing that made that my
career explode be kind enough for me
with South high five he was a bad guy
you would do self high five high five be
missing what they're bye-bye yeah I
loved it but you know the diamond cutter
one of my my greatest moments was I got
a phone call from Jake and alls I heard
was where I pick up the phone
congratulations
oh my Jake he's like yeah I said
congratulations for what he said
reinventing the DDT which was his move
in the 80s and it was the move of the
eighties yeah and my move was absolutely
move the nineties and today you can't
watch an independent wrestling show and
not see like 12 of them there's so many
ways to do it yeah so guys try I mean I
just sometimes my jaw drops and I see
Frankie Kazarian freaking catch one out
of friggin the moon like this is an
example here's they say this is the best
diamond cutter ever Eddie Guerrero takes
it
whoa Wow
I lost my mind that day because it's a
nice move but yeah he walked up to me
and Eddie was one of the greatest ever
Eddie Guerrero ever you know and a great
guy he came up to me because you movie
super over and he knows I'm going over
he's like ad you ever think about doing
diamond cutter I have a powerbomb I was
like I don't even do that and I grabbed
mine he goes boost me up with your
shoulder so I roll him up on my shoulder
and he says alright boost me
so all's I did was like throw him and he
spun and he slid down my back and landed
on the ground I want
Wow Eddie if we could time that I only
did that once
yeah well can you need somebody like
Eddie Guerrero right
yo Rey Mysterio yeah yeah I just say he
was phenomenal in a ring and a great guy
but you have to pick the other guy up
and it's a lot of work you know I do I
mean you can do the move without picking
them up and that's why a lot of people
do it cuz you could do it to anybody but
for it to look that cool you're right
you're not trying to live cuz they're so
heavy right yeah pounds so Sam it sounds
like you actually read positively on
some boy yeah I did because you yelled
at me and told me that I had to I wasn't
gonna show up and not not read it you
know it was funny cuz stone cold he only
read the first chapter yeah that was the
other thing when you told me stone cold
said that he wished that he read it like
a TV please telling me to read it and
stone cold wish that he read it I'd have
some balls to walk in here and not have
read the book but the book it's
available now positively unstoppable the
art of owning it and it's everything so
you know if you love DDP and you want to
just get more DDP get the book if you
have no idea what's going on but this
all sounds interesting
get the book it's like help it's half or
two it's a quarter memoir it's a quarter
self-help it's a quarter of fitness it's
a
I mean everything's in some kids it's
it's one of the things too that fits
into our program you know so well that
goes now because with the app have you
ever looked at a rap I don't think I
haven't looked at the app now the app
has like over 180 workouts again it
started with laying in bed and go to a
chair and work your way up to so that
wouldn't he said make the DDP Y your own
you know that's the way those biceps are
still flaring but they sure can we see
your chest yeah let's take a look and
print in his chest I just lifted this
shirt oh my god let me see that come
over here see the thumbs the fingers
there's the index the middle finger you
can see the different fingers that's
amazing you got to get that tattooed on
look up Rob look so you think it
pictures is awesome yeah and get the
flash drive is that a Badge of Courage
or not absolutely it's courage it's
honor it's everything
wow what a great then literally the
handprint you can see the finger
separation my wife was going though what
does he do that your fans ever asked you
to do that it like signings they do all
the time yeah I know I'm not doing that
yeah just waiting for insult like that
you just hit him too hard and they're
hitting you with in an assault lawsuit
or something like what do you feel that
on your chest oh yeah so back to the app
all right the app the all the different
workouts but I've also got recipes on
there so when you tell me what should I
eat I'm not even gonna tell you what to
eat I'm gonna cook it for you and we
could be me and Brenda or me and one of
my kids you know or one of my favorite
chefs and I I show you how to eat real
food and explain you know what what is
that we're doing in literally it's a
cooking show and then I got motivational
Monday's every Monday there's another
motivation it's on over 180 motivational
Monday's up there so when people tell me
out the press they are now down they are
well what do you focus on what is your
lifestyle wrapped around if it's all
around negative [ __ ] of course you're
gonna be depressed yeah you know
yes surround yourself like like I don't
ever watch the news mainly because it's
[ __ ] depressing you know so I don't
want to hear how this unity is
Donald Trump get Clem's in a whole bunch
of fast food oh you know I can't watch
it I can't I can't watch it
I can't watch CNN or I was actually
watching for a while and I was getting
so mad
Brenda walked over and turned off the TV
said you're not allowed to watch the
news anymore Wow
cuz it's a negative it I want I want to
be surrounding around positive [ __ ]
because you can have that too and that
positively unstoppable I believe gives
people like it teaches them how to live
that same lifestyle and that's all I'm
really trying to do is give them one
more tool to help move in their life and
yes change in your life that's cool but
owning your life that's a whole
different level are you on in your life
Jim yeah okay the disastrous parts it's
my fault as long as you own it brother
as long as you're good with it it's my
fault